hi rosie hi joe
i'm so happy to see your lovely
beautiful face i'm so happy to see you
too
and by the way we actually
did a film together that i didn't even
mention
in your incredible body of work i was
thinking about white men
can't jump this morning and we'll get to
that in a second because there's
something pertinent that's happening in
the world that
applies but i just love you
and i had the privilege and pleasure of
getting to work with you
20 years ago was it yeah man
yeah so uh and we're both still rocking
and rolling you know what i'm saying so
that's a great thing
you're right it is a great thing like
it's so we're so
lucky to have any longevity
in this fickle industry and
to have the privilege of
having jobs
i love you for saying that yeah but um
riding in cars with boys i was so happy
to be a part of that
and i actually had no choice because
penny marshall calls me up i
i had knew i i've known her prior got
rested so
and she calls me and she goes wow it's
penny
so you're gonna do this film like a what
she goes yeah
listen just show up on set it's gonna be
with drew barrymore she's great she's a
doll you love her
that's how that's how i came to be in
your movie oh my
great gosh i'm well first of all i'm
shocked that penny even said i was a
doll because you know
penny is like a real task master but
penny
is someone who yes god rest her soul
is someone who made one of the greatest
marks
you know in our world with her comedy
and talent
filmmaking and we have the heated seed
together
and i was so scared because i was in my
early 20s and i was trying to play like
in my mid-30s and i didn't think i could
pull it off and i was so nervous
in this scene with you here i actually
take a look
why are you starting this a hundred
thousand dollars
what pray
i ever asked you for a dime of child
support
i know we like matt said hello and then
did a day of arguing but it was such a
just so exciting to work with you i
have loved you since you came onto the
scene
and into the world and you were such a
phenomenon
so unique so interesting that you
possess
just you're so just oh
i was thinking this morning about when
you were like foods with the letter q
in white man can't jump and i was
thinking about it and then obviously
alex trebek um you know just
uh left us and he's so beloved and you
did
that scene with him that really famous
scene from white men can't jump
and um your character gloria is on
jeopardy in the film and
what was it like to work with him
it was an honor and i was
beyond thrilled i'm a nerd and a geek
and i love game shows and i always
watched
uh jeopardy and then wheel of fortune
with my aunt
and um i couldn't believe i you know i
was going to be in a scene with this man
and we had no pre-rehearsal with alex so
when we went to
shoot he walks out on the stage and we
were on the actual jeopardy stage
and my heart just went up in my throat
and
if you see in the scene my shoulders are
like this because i was so nervous
and i knew my lines but my speech
impediment came out and instead of
you know saying the word correctly i
said mousuvius
and i pause and i'm thinking to myself
holy crap i just messed up
and he goes that's not correct but we
will check with the judges
the judges say okay okay and
and i was like oh my gosh and that was
all adelib
on alex's part he was so smooth and
everything and
when uh the director ron shelton yelled
cut we all was like yeah
that was awesome and i said well can i
do it again so
so the mistake's not in there and the
director goes oh no that's in there
yeah that's gonna be history and i went
over to alec afterwards and i said sir
it's such an honor to meet you my aunt
and i watch you every single night
and i just love you and and can i give
you a hug
and he said i was going to ask you the
same but you know i am a gentleman
and i didn't want to be rude and i went
oh my god and i just hugged him and i
remember
smearing all my makeup on his clothes
and i felt so bad
and um but he was just wonderful an uh
not just a national treasure a worldwide
treasure
and and a great loss a great loss you
know but what he's given us we will
always have so that's a wonderful thing
you're absolutely right what a beautiful
thing
to have a summation of this man who has
been
in our homes making us think
and exercising our minds and being
competitive with one another
and ourselves i mean he has been a
conductor
of our lives for decades what a perfect
thing to
say about him now switching gears
your new show the flight attendant i
feel like i need to take xanax
when i watch it because i'm so anxious
and so excited
and it is a show that just keeping you
on your toes and pulse and all the
decisions she's making is driving me
crazy and it's so good
and it's all the rage and this is the
biggest show right now that everybody is
water cooler talking about
and you are so amazing in it and i am
loving it and i'm tearing my hair out
and yet i'm like more more and more like
a rat on a feeder
are is this a great experience are you
having a good time with the show are you
surprised by the phenomenon response
i'm it was a great experience i had a
ball on the show
i'm not surprised by the response
because
just even uh you know when they offered
me the role
oh my god drew can you believe i i i
turned down the roll
when they found out me yes cause i'm
scared to fly and i hate flying i hate
the whole thing
i hate the whole thing right and i was
so stupid
and and um then my manager tar calls me
back and he said
uh kaylee cuckoo's not accepting no for
an answer she wants to meet with you and
i go oh god
and they said she's going to meet with
you around the corner uh
you know um in your neighborhood i was
like well she's going to come to my
neighborhood in brooklyn that's cool
we met and she goes why don't you want
to do this role and i said well i don't
like to fly she goes you do know it's
called the flight attendant and we will
be flying i said i know
but you know what can i do and we both
started cracking up
and you know we were high-fiving it was
supposed to be a 10-15 minute coffee
chat it turned in over an
hour she had me at hello but i kept her
waiting for two weeks later
just give my final answer yes but i i as
soon as she walked in the door i knew i
wanted to work with this young lady
she's amazing
this is her project she put it together
she was the boss
she ran things and you never felt like
she was
heavy-handed she let she allowed every
single body
on that set to play their position you
know and just
didn't really interfere in a really bad
way in a real bossy way
and so i'm really happy for her i'm
happy for this project but i'm really
happy for her because it's tough in this
business
especially for women and she just did it
and i'm really happy and the entire case
is fabulous
we had so much fun it's disgusting and
i'm just so
happy and relieved that everybody loves
it as much as we do
well it is very powerful she is
extraordinary and i'm dying to talk to
her about it like if i ever can
i'm so happy to have gotten to speak to
you and see you
again after all of these years i think
the world of you i am rooting you on i'm
so happy for the success of this show
the flight attendant is streaming now on
hbo max with new episodes every thursday
it's a nail biter oh my gosh rosie prez
you are
the coolest thank you so much for coming
we'll be right back
you